[Aplausos]
por qué
algunas personas logran hacerle un hueco
al universo es decir porque hay un antes
y después de una instant porque hay un
antes y un después de newton no porque
porque como es que estas personas logran
trascender
la pregunta bueno me ha llevado a
investigar todas estas cuestiones y
déjenme practicar ponemos averiguado
hemos intentado averiguar desde cosas
históricas hasta fenómenos psicológicos
y estas cuestiones y hemos tratado de
entender y llegamos a una conclusión que
hoy les voy a compartir y déjenme
platicarles una historia que es a mí me
gusta muchísimo esta es una niña una
campesina del siglo 15 ella vivía en un
pueblito que se llama hombre mí en
francia
muy cerca de inglaterra y esta niña
bueno es campesina pero en el pueblo se
acostumbraban no pagar impuestos era una
ordenanza del gobierno francés de la
corona francesa que hacía que en el
pueblo en donde min no se pagaran
impuestos de repente por algunos tejes y
manejes que suceden ahí surge una guerra
con inglaterra y el rey francés cae y de
repente el pueblo se encuentra gobernado
por
y se les imponen estas cuestiones de los
impuestos
y aquí salga la historia para
preguntarles cuando nosotros nos suben
la gasolina o con otras estas cuestiones
suceden actualmente tenemos muchísimas
maneras de asumir estas cuestiones las
más comunes y que también incluso esta
línea tenía de opción para hacer ante
ese estímulo externo que tenía del
cambio en su pueblo la primera que tiene
es el bus que le valga gorro
esa es la opción que todos tenemos nos
oye pero espera medios era una niña
tengo 13 años soy campesina no sé
absolutamente nada con los impuestos que
vendan a burro no esa es una de las
primeras cosas que podemos hacer de
hecho a muchos los vale gorro que suba
la gasolina
otra opción
más común todavía es decir quiero ser el
mejor entonces bueno ya me puse un
impuesto no sólo en la gasolina pero yo
quiero ser el mejor entonces todos los
impulsan a que seamos los mejores y nos
dicen no si éste tienes que ser el mejor
entonces esta niña lo que pudo haber
hecho es decir soy la mejor quiero que
todo mundo sepa que yo pago mis
impuestos y que sigo las ordenanzas del
rey su opción
esta niña lo que decide realmente es ser
diferente fíjense fíjense lo que hace
esta niña
primero díganme por favor necesito que
en este punto usemos esto del teléfono y
me digan la edad que ustedes tienen
pónganme por favor queda tienen vamos a
ver la edad que ustedes tienen la edad
de la audiencia
y pues aquí los niños serán los que van
a responder primero y no increíble bueno
pues bueno aquí tenemos ya más o menos
las edades les voy a platicar esta niña
esta niña
muchos años que bien es la mejor
respuesta estos me gustan esos son
diferentes y eso me gusta un poco
rebelde el muchacho pero
pero dice que muchos
y ese último símbolo significar así como
que extra grande
oigan pues esta niña entonces la
decisión que tome será diferente fíjense
lo que ella dice lo que ella dice es
oigan tengo 13 años esta línea tiene 13
años y decide decirle al mundo aunque yo
me voy a hacer la mejor ni voy a hacer
ni me va a valer gorro yo a mis 13 años
decidió decir una historia y decido
decirles que escucho voces y esas voces
me están diciendo que tengo que ayudarle
al rey de francia a recuperar la corona
fíjense a los 13 años la decisión que
toma la niña era campesina y dice yo voy
a ayudar le voy a ayudar a salvar su
majestad francesa para que recuperen la
corona obviamente ella estaba expuesta a
este estímulo de los impuestos no quería
que su pueblo pagar impuestos porque eso
implicaba muchas muchas penas para ellos
y ella decide entonces ser diferente que
le sucedió bueno muchas cosas sucedieron
por ser diferente la iglesia católica
condenó y la mato en la hoguera por
bruja no dijeron que ella escuchaba
cosas y fue nuestros de locos no es una
brujería tiene implicaciones el ser
diferente y una de ellas fue la hoguera
pero después la iglesia
rectificó dijo si nos equivocamos
perdónanos este y te vas a convertir en
santa juana de arco santa cuando dejar
cuenta patrona de francia y bueno se
celebró hace casi un mes el 30 de mayo
pero y ella logró impactar al mundo de
esta manera simplemente por ser
diferente y esto esto llama muchísimo la
atención y llegamos a esta conclusión
miren trascienden porque deciden ser
diferente a la generalidad de la gente
de la producción de su época eso es la
constante que hemos visto einstein era
diferente
newton era diferente
'juana de arco' era diferente aquí la
pregunta es
es ser diferente eso es mucha gente lo
confunde con ser creativo
ser diferente lo primero que nos lleva
es inmediatamente al diccionario bueno
ahora ya casi los diccionarios de papel
como en mi época ahora todos son
virtuales y podemos ver aquí
que dice que diferente
un poco corriente o se aparta de lo
normal
ordinario por el contrario significa
también que no destaca por nada especial
y se encuentra en lo que se considera
normal salen dos veces aparece la
palabra normal y esto me lleva a mis
raíces
a mis raíces ingenieriles no les voy a
explicar muy rápidamente usando esto que
se llama la campana de gauss no se
espanten sobre todo los adultos rodillas
de las aves pero los adultos no se
espanten porque esto es una campana de
gauss y les voy a explicar para qué
sirve la parte del centro la parte azul
es lo que se llama la normal en el
centro tenemos la contracción a lo
normal sale es como se saca una normal
una normal es el promedio de todas las
cosas vamos a tomar un ejemplo para que
no sea muy profundo el asunto y vamos a
hacerlo con las estaturas salen por
favor díganme cuál es su estatura ahí en
la en el aparatito pongan
su estatura bien hoy tenemos un 182 por
ejemplo que creo que es de los más altos
no ayuda a encontrar en esta vista el
más alto y el más bajito 182 hasta
ahorita va el más alto no más que yo
ok
ahí está el 150 perfecto bueno miren
para poder aplicar les voy explicarles
qué es lo que pasa porque les quiero les
quiero platicar cómo funciona lo normal
no sé si ustedes toman en un 82 mil 150
más o menos para dar como unos 75 eso es
lo normal y la normal se encuentra al
centro de la campana
entonces fíjense como hablamos y como
estos lenguajes interfieren en nuestro
pensamiento
para la derecha es 185 y para la
izquierda es 165 al centro tenemos en
unos 175 sale que es el promedio
entonces lo normal es entre 185 y 165
que pasa cuando una persona mide unos 50
rusia es rarito no ya ya ya tendrán a
cesarle y se va a la parte de la
etiqueta el emmy de 195 pues también es
rarito no y fíjense como la mayoría
estamos en la zona azul es la zona
normal entonces cuando tradición yuturi
es normal qué significación rica que es
igual a todos su importancia en el rango
de lo parecido de lo igual de lo
ordinario cuando tenías 150 195 ya estás
en los rangos de afuera ahora qué pasa
cuando uno mide 145 no ya se nos viene
de este lado del 2% y eso significa que
eres más rarito no quieres rarísimo o te
vas a los dos metros eso es rarísimo
también dos metros incluso se les
dificulta entrar en las puertas
pues acá tenemos amigos 90 centímetros
si es que existen creo que sí 90
centímetros y podría tenemos a los de
210 esto que estamos observando estamos
observando que lo normal es lo que todo
el mundo es se fijan y
bueno esto es exactamente lo normal lo
chistoso del asunto es que el mejor se
encuentra en esta zona normal es decir
hay mucha competencia es mucha gente
todos los mejores el problema que
tenemos con los mejores es que es
realmente
están ahí y es muy completo
ser el mejor entonces la lección aquí es
un poco que mientras tú seas diferente
vas a tener un menos competencia
qué pasa si eres diferente lo que va a
pasar si eres diferente ya no lo decía
coco chanel es que vas a ser
irremplazable cuando tú eres diferente
te conviertes en en una persona
irremplazable pero además nos dice
mehamed morán un autor que les
recomiendo leer es que tienes que ser
diferente para que te puedas ver
claramente entre la multitud
si eres diferente entonces te vuelves
incomparable alguien ha oído esto de
comparar peras con manzanas no no se
pueden comparar porque son completamente
diferentes entonces son incomparables
y más pasa cuando tú eres cuando tú eres
diferente
tú van a hablar de ti vas a generar
fanáticos pero también vas a generar van
a generar enemigos el ser diferente
definitivamente te hace que la gente te
voltea a ver y empiezan a hablar alguien
tiene amigos que sean de alguna manera
diferentes y entonces empiezan a hablar
de ellos es una cosa absolutamente común
van a hablar de ti no hablan de ti
directamente entonces cuando tú eres
diferente hablan de ti y la siguiente
que es tu propia categoría cuando
einstein quería de alguna manera o
cuando aysén se revela como físico no
teníamos dónde ponerlo no sabíamos si
era en física euclidiana o física a
newton newtoniana entonces lo ponen en
la física de la activista crea su propia
categoría la siguiente trasciendes aquí
lo que sucede es que finalmente llegamos
al objetivo de nuestra pregunta inicial
cuando tú eres diferente trasciende y
este es un 'bonus track' hoy en día
te haces millonario cuando tú eres
diferente ahí está el dinero no entra el
dinero en ser mejor piénsenlo
hay muchos mejores normas no les ha
pasado entonces que pasan por alguna
carretera y se encuentran a la mejor
birria no con los mejores caldos son las
mejores que sabías no todos son el mejor
sin embargo cuando tú eres diferente el
dinero mágicamente empieza a caer te la
siente
es característica de una persona
diferente se las voy a practicar la
siguiente
una persona diferente es única una
persona diferente de alguna manera la
siguiente por favor también es diferente
pero valorado
en algo que es valorado por su audiencia
no es simplemente un contreras no es una
persona que diga verde rojo azul
amarillo sino que es esa diferencia la
centra en algo en lo que las personas
valoramos
esa diferencia debe ser también fácil de
comunicar y específica hoy julio cuál es
tu diferencia no tengo bigote no eso es
algo específico de comunicar 4 tienes
que elaborar mucho tu diferencia dejas
de ser diferente porque es muy compleja
la explicación
como ser diferente bueno
dice el meollo del asunto porque cuando
tú preguntas cuando tú ya creemos
revelado todos estos secretos de la
trascendencia la cuestión es cómo es que
yo llegaría a ser diferente al juez y
primero como no ser diferente
no van a ser nunca diferente a través de
expectativas y fortalezas que son las
expectativas imagínense que yo le digo a
alguien
su perfil
como sea pero me tanto se supone esa es
mi expectativa que me seas fiel te voy a
tratar muy bien
cienciano expectativas me explico yo no
podría considerar andar con alguien que
no fuera fiel esas son las expectativas
jamás lograremos ser diferentes si nos
vamos a hacer las expectativas luego las
fortalezas que son las fortalezas las
fortalezas es algo que yo hago bien y
que los demás también hacen bien por
ejemplo entregar productos en 30 minutos
lo hace bien domino's lo hace bien pizza
hot todas esas fortalezas y genio
industrial por ejemplo y en mi
generación hay otros 150 ingenieros
industriales eso no es una diferencia
donde provienen de dónde vienen las
diferencias de donde si vienen las
diferencias
bueno cuando ven ustedes todas estas
cuestiones todas estas palabras la más
fiel punto a la asesoría personalizada a
tradición del respaldo no son
diferencias estas son expectativas son
cosas básicas de dónde proviene ahora si
las diferencias darle a la siguiente por
favor como si ser diferente el gran
secreto es a través de su talento
el gran secreto que tenemos para ser
diferentes es que todos nacimos con un
talento individual
todos tenemos este don que nos fue
regalado y que a través de los años lo
que ha sucedido es que ese don lo hemos
supeditado a lo que estudiamos ustedes
son ingenieros o son arquitectos o son
psicólogos o son pedagogos pero ustedes
tienen un talento individual si ese
talento la siguiente por favor si ese
talento que es un atributo
característica especial la siguiente les
suma su formación académica en ese
momento estás convirtiéndote en la
siguiente en una persona diferente a esa
a ese talento a esa formación académica
tú le sumas tú porque su propósito el
por qué haces las cosas esas cuestiones
que traemos en la panza y que hacemos
que no se emocionen y esas cosas que
enamoran en ese propósito y le sumas
entonces si te conviertes en una persona
más diferente en la siguiente por favor
entonces tiene su talento tu formación
académica y tu propósito ya con estas
tres variables tu te conviertes
diferente pero qué es lo que pasa
todos nos vamos aún no nos vamos a la
formación académica
y olvidamos nuestro talento y a veces no
tenemos nuestro propósito la siguiente
por favor tenemos también otra fuente
del diferente la diferenciación que es
el servir entender que nunca se trata de
nosotros que siempre es una cuestión de
servir a los demás esas personas a las
que tú sirves después de servir de
maneras muy distintas la siguiente por
favor o dedicarte a un nicho de mercado
no sé si a que conozca por ejemplo las
tiendas para zurdos bueno son tiendas
especializadas para eso ellos son
diferentes porque se dedicaron se
enfocaron a un grupo de personas muy
particulares la siguiente tenemos
entonces aquí varias fuentes de
diferencia primero nuestro talento que
es la base después la formación
académica el propósito servir y un nicho
específico todo esto nos van haciendo
nos van dando diferentes la siguiente
por favor
hacer sentir diferente a las personas
cuando tú hay personas muy serviciales
por ejemplo aquí vimos mariana una niña
de las brigadas que nos ayudan es un
niño tremendamente servicial y es
diferente porque hace sentir a la gente
diferente porque te hace sentir especial
eso es una fuente de diferencia de
diferencia la siguiente por favor la
siente
tienes una forma diferente de hacer las
cosas tus procesos en lugar de todo
mundo en la mañana nos levantamos y
metemos a mañana y nos vamos al trabajo
a lo mejor esto podrías hacer que te
fueras al trabajo luego te durmiera si
luego te bañaras ese cambio no es muy
práctico no pero ese cambio de orden de
hacer las cosas y hacerlas diferentes a
los demás es también una fuente de
diferencia la siguiente estar en lugares
más convenientes también eso es un lugar
o es una fuente de conveniencia no
fuente de diferencia la siguiente por
favor
y finalmente la imagen está la imagen
también te da una forma de ser diferente
entonces ustedes tienen la siguiente por
favor postres tienen aquí el mapa de
cómo ser diferentes la base central es
su talento la base central es reconocer
para que son buenos que es lo que les
gusta hacer que es lo que naturalmente
funcionan y les gusta hacer eso que a lo
mejor arte es un hobby ese es su talento
y todos estos elementos que giran en
torno a su talento es la fuente de
diferencia que los va a hacer diferentes
entonces la siguiente por favor dejen de
pelearse porque dejen de buscar ser el
mejor
realmente hay muchos mejores el mundo
necesita 'juana de arco' el mundo
necesita a einstein y estos einstein son
diferentes los invito de verdad traten
de en vez de ser el mejor ser diferentes
gracias
[Aplausos]